[Music]
on this Wednesday night holiday travel
chaos the thousands already stranded
and the winter storm still looming the
millions under extreme weather alerts
and how it could snarl your plans it's
going to be a challenging next few days
Ukraine's president Goes to Washington
what a great honor his gift his message
and his plea on his first foreign visit
since Russia invaded his country
parting with plastic could giving up
single-use Plastics have unintended
consequences and the power of quiet
philanthropy I am just incredibly filled
with absolute joy and love over her gift
the extraordinary the quest by a
Winnipeg businesswoman that will last
for Generations
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us what a
way to ring in the first official day of
winter thousands of people who plan
trips for the holidays have had them
delayed and anyone traveling in the days
ahead is advised to pack extra patients
an Arctic air flow and heavy snowfall
snarled flights at Vancouver's airport
causing a cascading effect hundreds of
flights have been canceled or delayed
that's left people stuck on planes for
hours or sleeping at the airport and
more weather systems are coming extreme
cold weather alerts are now in place for
Canada's North into BC as well as on the
Prairies and parts of Southern Ontario
Tracy nagai has our top story on the
cold the snow the cancellations and how
it could impact your travel
passengers packed the Vancouver
International Airport desperate to get
home but for some it could still be days
they told me that I can only fly on the
25th of December and thousands of
Travelers worldwide have yet to start
their trip with ybr announcing its
limiting inbound international flights
until Friday in order to deal with the
backlog I'm unfortunately I hate to be
the bearer of bad news but I have to be
frank with with folks it's going to be a
challenging next few days and there are
going to be continued delays and
cancellations WestJet has announced more
than 550 flights have been canceled
since Sunday the airline telling people
with confirmed travel between now and
December 26th they can proactively
cancel their Flight online for a full
refund the impact of the delays in
Vancouver Rippling out across the
country and Canada is not out of the
woods yet with the country bracing for
another blast of cold weather this low
pressure area will deepen rapidly as it
moves through the Great Lakes bringing
rain a flash freeze snow Gusty winds
over a hundred kilometers per hour and
blizzard conditions lasting into the
weekend eventually extending into Quebec
parts of the maritimes as well the cold
air comes in behind the low the plunging
temperatures only adding to passengers
frustrations fueled by a lack of
communication long lines and wait times
right now we're just waiting in line but
we didn't hear anything from any of the
staff
told us that the waiting is half hour
okay the half hour goes to two hours the
two hours goes to four six eight nine
nine hours we're at the plate sitting
and waiting to open passenger rights
experts saying well cancellations and
delays may have been unavoidable at YVR
due to the snowstorm like the tarmac
delays are unacceptable I would suggest
that passengers sue the airline for
damages keeping them for that long on
the aircraft that was not excusable for
many traveling on a hope and a prayer
this week if I only have wings I'm gonna
go and fly back home perhaps some
comfort found in wishful thinking in
Calgary Teresa guy Global News
Global News has obtained more
information about a national security
document that detailed an extensive
network backed by the Chinese government
which allegedly tried to interfere in
the 2019 federal election the story was
first broken by global news and now our
investigative team has reviewed an
unredacted intelligence document from
2020 that explains how the network
operated and allegedly sought to
influence politicians and their staff
Mackenzie Gray from our Ottawa Bureau
has more details Mackenzie
well Donna this is a rare inside look
into what the government knew about
alleged Chinese interference in the 2019
vote an unredacted Memo from the privy
Council Office that was viewed by global
news outlines an extensive network of
community groups being used by Beijing
to conceal the flow of funds between
Chinese officials and Canadian members
of an election interference Network now
the goal of that network was to
influence government officials into
taking specific stances on China's
issues of interest and the way the group
hope to execute that was by targeting
influencing at least 11 candidates in
the greater Toronto area running for
both the Liberals and conservatives
according to this briefing now those
targeted candidates had varying levels
of knowledge of the sophisticated scheme
the document States some are likely
unaware of these influencing efforts
While others are willingly cooperating
and one key thing here Donna The
Briefing doesn't say the names of those
11 candidates Mackenzie do we know who
was part of the network allegedly trying
to influence the election
the PCO document says individuals
working for the Chinese Consulate local
community leaders Canadian politicians
and their staff were all involved with
this network and it was set up by an
organization called the united front
work department which is an arm of the
Chinese Communist party now this
department wasn't just offering
Financial Health the ufwd is also likely
to offer candidates logistical support
favorable media coverage and
endorsements according to the memo now
China denies it interferes in other
nations but Canadian intelligence
officials dispute that and at the end of
this briefing they gave an ominous
warning predicting foreign interference
efforts are likely to be more persistent
and pervasive in future elections Donna
okay Mackenzie gray and Ottawa thanks
what led a group of eight teenage girls
to allegedly swarm and stab a man to
death over the weekend that is the
troubling question at the heart of a
Toronto police investigation the
suspects between the ages of 13 and 16
are charged with second-degree murder
police say the 59-year-old man was
killed in downtown Toronto on Sunday
under the youth criminal justice act the
accused girls cannot be named Toronto
police say the suspects are not from one
specific geographic location and it's
believed they met online as for what led
to the stabbing a woman claiming to be
the victim's friend tells Global News
she saw what happened
they
take it already and then and he stopped
them and then they uh
they they stopped the cliffer along and
then they hit him all beating all
breeding
we asked Toronto police whether an
attempted theft took place during the
encounter with the victim they tell
Global News a possible theft of alcohol
was involved the victim has not been
identified by police who are working to
notify his family it's believed the same
group of suspects was involved in
another altercation prior to this one
we're learning more about the 73 year
old gunman who took the lives of five
people and injured one other at a condo
building north of Toronto on Sunday the
estranged children of Francesco Village
say he was a controlling and abusive
husband and father in a statement shared
by Ontario's police Watchdog the special
investigations unit the three daughters
expressed they are deeply heartbroken
for the victims families to honor the
lives of those killed a candlelight
vigil is being planned for tonight in
Vaughn where veli went on the shooting
rampage before he was shot by the police
Ukraine's president is in Washington his
first trip outside the country since
Russia invaded and Vladimir zielinski
told President Biden a just peace with
Russia means no compromises he's in
Washington to make the case for
continued support for the defense of
Ukraine tonight he got a long standing
ovation before his speech in English to
the U.S Congress
[Music]
Against All Odds and doom and gloom
scenarius Ukraine didn't fall
Ukraine is alive
and kicking your money is not charity
it's an investment in the global
security and democracy that we handle in
the most responsible way
as Russia's war in Ukraine drags into a
second year there is a push especially
among some Republicans to cut back on
American Aid and weapons to Ukraine
Jackson prosco reports on this
high-stakes visit to the American
Capital
this is a mission to thank the American
people for their support
for President Vladimir zielenski it's
also about survival a chance to stress
the importance of American money and
weapons in the nearly year-long fight
against Russia he presented President
Joe Biden with the Ukrainian military
cross a gift from troops on the front
line all depreciation to you because of
all Mr President for your big support
and Leadership you know it's an honor to
be by your side in the united defense
against what is a brutal brutal force
awakens less than 24 hours earlier
zielinski was on the front lines himself
traveling under cover of Darkness first
to Poland then to a U.S military flight
to Washington arriving just as the Biden
Administration announced the delivery of
more Aid
including the highly Advanced Patriot
missile defense system I think that this
support for Ukraine is based in our
values
it's based in our strategic interests we
know
that Ukraine has to win this war against
the Russia against the Russians
increasingly there are Skeptics in the
U.S Republicans who want to turn off the
Taps and force Ukraine to go it alone or
negotiate with its Invader the days of
endless cash and Military materiel to
Ukraine are numbered zelenski seems
confident American support will endure
arguing Ukraine's battle is the world's
fight because we really fight for our
common Victory against this tyranny
that is real life
and we will win
and I really want
win together there's no mistaking the
urgency of the message as the coming
months may be the most arduous in the
war both Ukraine and Russia are
preparing new offensives in the depths
of winter with the end of the brutality
nowhere in sight
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
the
a tragic story out of Montreal a young
Ukrainian girl was laid to rest there
today the seven-year-old was killed in a
hit-and-run last week she was a refugee
who came to Canada just a few months ago
as Mike Armstrong reports she was
seeking safety from the war at home
foreign
most at this funeral didn't know Maria
they wanted to be here because they knew
her story my heart is broken
and I can't imagine this
strategy for this family Maria
legendkowska had only been in Canada for
two months she came with her mother and
two siblings her father stayed in
Ukraine to fight well he did make it to
the funeral the Canadian government
expedited the Visa process allowing him
to be with his family the Canadian
authorities obviously understood that
this is those are special circumstances
that warranted an accelerated process
and he made it back on Sunday the
accident happened here last Tuesday
morning Maria and her older brother and
older sister were walking to school and
crossing the street the speed limit here
is 30. it's a school zone and it's one
of those places you're supposed to be
very careful
Maria was hit by a car with her brother
and sister watching she died of her
injuries later that day there were other
kids there witnessing the the Collision
it's really uh devastating
now the driver of the vehicle didn't
stop he would only turn himself into
police later in the day the 45 year old
man was charged with Hit and Run he
appeared in court Friday and was
released on bail
but at a memorial service Tuesday for
Maria her mother called for clemency
he says the accused has children of his
own and that she doesn't want him to
suffer more she knows that it was
intentional and she wishes only the best
for uh for the man who did this
the plan right now is for Maria's mother
and siblings to stay in Canada for the
next couple of months the father will be
around as well he's going to stay to
help the family settle and mourn in two
or three months he'll go back to Ukraine
and back to fighting in the war
Mike Armstrong Global News Montreal
the debate over ditching single-use
Plastics coming up as Canadians part
ways with plastic are alternatives
really that green plus the accelerated
plan towards fully electric cars in
Canada
new rules are now in place to help
reduce plastic waste in Canada the first
phase of a national ban on single-use
Plastics is now in effect that means
many disposables like straws Cutlery or
grocery bags will soon become things of
the past Toria Israeli looks at the
pluses of the transition as well as its
downsides
that crinkling sound at the checkout is
gone replaced by the quieter cotton
alternative plastic bags are now relics
in grocery stores with customers
reaching for reusable instead
everybody's just going to get used to it
so yeah I think it's the right way to go
and Canadians use a staggering 15
billion plastic bags every year they can
take a thousand years to disintegrate
that's why provinces and cities have
already brought in their own plastic bag
bands all in an effort to stop littering
Landscapes and clogging waterways if we
went to Lake Ontario right now at the at
Toronto Harbor
we would find something like 20 million
little pieces of plastic in a square
kilometer Canada is the latest country
to introduce a ban on single-use plastic
the UK Australia and India have all
introduced similar measures but there
are questions about whether the
alternatives are as green as we think
there are some customers like seniors or
students that forget their bags either
in their dorm or they our seniors forget
them at home every time customers forget
the reusable bags pile up sitting around
I would say about 10 and we've had a
clear wrap York University Professor
Calvin Lakin researches waste management
and says the ban will have unintended
consequences it's a lot of feel good and
not do good policy a United Nations
study found the Alternatives take more
energy and carbon to make cotton bags
need to be used up to 150 times before
they're considered more environmentally
friendly for reusable plastic bags that
number is 20. paper bags cut down on
litter but in most cases have a larger
impact on the climate the paper
decomposes and releases all of that
methane and or embodied carbon and
Shoppers May wind up buying more Plastic
Products to line their garbage cans or
pick up after pets some search
single-use Plastics are absolutely bad
and some are actually really great but
in order to figure that out we need to
actually do the work we can't just
assume one way or the other questions
about whether banning single-use plastic
is a double-edged sword
tariya isri Global News Ottawa
electric vehicle Ambitions the federal
government's new targets for Ed sales
the Canadian government is accelerating
its targets for electric vehicles by
2026 one-fifth of all Passenger cars
SUVs and trucks sold in Canada will need
to run on electricity and by 2035 every
passenger vehicle sold in Canada will
need to be electric as Ross Lord reports
there's a long road ahead to meet those
requirements
at less than six percent of the light
duty Market in 2021 electric vehicles
are a small but growing piece of
Canada's Auto industry in the last two
years that number has more than doubled
we're happening fastest in Quebec in
British Columbia two provinces that have
regulated sales targets the federal
government is announcing its first major
set of regulations from a planet
published in April the new regulations
mean by 2026 20 of all vehicles sold in
Canada will be required to run on
electricity four years later that Target
moves up to 60 percent and by 2035
electric vehicle sales will be required
to account for every passenger vehicle
sold in Canada
the government and electric vehicle
promoters suggest that mandating EV
sales will force car dealers to make
sure there are plenty in stock we have
to make sure that Canadians have much
easier access to EVS without having to
wait anywhere between three months to
three years environmental groups say the
regulations will help move Canadians
away from gas engines as will incentives
of up to five thousand dollars in
rebates for electric vehicle buyers
another Tipping Point oil and gas
companies facing an existential threat
are investing billions in EV charging
stations but others note there are
downsides an increase in mining to
extract lithium and Cobalt for Ev
batteries has caused other problems for
the environment like claims of
contaminated drinking water
controversies that are spreading to
Canada as a Quebec company plans to
expand lithium mining to fill the
growing demand the government is
sidestepping that part of the equation
the focus is always is on making sure
that we're helping Canadians get access
to these vehicles we're making sure that
the vehicles are affordable and we are
making sure that we have clean air and
are tackling climate change she says the
government encourages provinces that
don't provide incentives like Ontario to
take a closer look at what's happening
with electric vehicle sales and
reconsider Ross Lord Global News
after four years on the surface of the
red planet NASA's Mars Insight Lander
has finally Fallen silent the Rover's
power levels have been dwindling for
months because of the Martian dust
coating at solar panels and now it's no
longer responding to Communications from
Earth
the probe landed in 2018 recording more
than 1300 so-called Mars Quakes and
sending back high definition pictures
and video complete with sound NASA says
the Insight team will keep trying to
contact Insight just in case
the gift of a lifetime next the
record-breaking donation from a
businesswoman to a Winnipeg charity
[Music]
we all know about the wealthy donors who
give money to hospitals or art galleries
because their name often ends up on the
building there is a certain Prestige to
that but there are also wealthy donors
who seek no recognition it's called
quiet philanthropy this year one
Winnipeg businesswoman gave the largest
gift ever made to a Canadian charity by
an individual and you've probably never
heard her name as Melissa ridgeen
explains that's exactly how she wanted
it it is with immense gratitude raising
funds for the community since 1921 the
Winnipeg Foundation is used to people
opening their wallets what we gifted to
community last year almost 85 million
dollars was distributed to over 1100
charities in the city
but last month one call from the estate
of a local businesswoman would see that
figure Jump by an estimated 25 million
dollars a year for decades Miriam Bergen
left her family's company to the
foundation a record-setting 500 million
dollar gift you just have to be in pause
of a bit of an awe about the love
for the city the love for Humanity I am
just incredibly filled with absolute joy
and love over her gift
of Appleton shares to be held in trust
by the Winnipeg Foundation to support
community of this city for generations
to come
Appleton Holdings operates as Edison
properties with a large portfolio of
residential and Commercial rental
properties around Winnipeg Bergen
willeds the gift at the time of her
passing earlier this year
Miriam was intensely private it's quite
possible that she would have chosen to
skip this type of an event
she was an unassuming person and did not
like the spotlight the daughter of
immigrants her father Martin Bergen
built the Edison property Empire and
with his wife Ruth quietly supported
Community organizations throughout his
life a legacy carried on by his daughter
Martin and ruthberg and felt that coming
to Canada was life-changing for
themselves and their families they never
lost sight of how lucky they were to
live here and were proud to be Canadians
and as many close out 2022 and are more
economic pressure Bridges hopes this act
inspires everybody to do what they can I
hope that this message of generosity
reminds everyone that you can open up
your heart at any time and make a
difference it doesn't matter about the
size it's about the act and if as a
community if we do that in love we will
move better together for future
Generations forever Melissa Ridge in
Global News Winnipeg
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is the Christmas Market at
Lansdowne Park in Ottawa Ontario we'd
love to see your festive photos please
email them to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]